one big sign of hope more and more
people are getting vaccinated
it really is great news something like
eight million people in california have
received the covid
19 vaccine now of course once you get
the vaccine
it's very natural to want to celebrate
and let everyone know that you got it
well one company is taking advantage of
people's natural desire
to let people know they got the shot
when you finally receive the covet 19
vaccine you'll get your very own
government issued proof of vaccination
card
but if you sign up for a knock you proof
you'll receive this giant foam cowboy
hat that lets the whole world know you
got the shot
it's the hat that says yo [ __ ] i'm
coveted immune and proud
not into hats want something even
sassier then hang your vaccine sign on
your back door with a my ascot vaxxed
butt patch
or get an enochu-proof gold teeth grill
that proudly shares your news
or even better our just vaccinated can
and sign package look at her go don't
feel like leaving home but still want to
share the news
no problem inocuproof
let them know you got jabbed